can you walk us through that storyline
and the North American issues that have
popped up as of a couple weeks ago I
wish I you know I've been so busy in the
last few days with other stuff I wish I
I don't feel like I'm as informed about
this as I would like to be but you know
as we all know there were there was
first the Chinese balloon that was shot
down which was clearly a spy balloon and
that was made very clear shot down over
the Atlantic Ocean and then over this
past weekend we had three more objects
shot down right we had one in Alaska on
February 2nd which they said was about
the size of a small car
another one in El Yukon Canada and
February 3rd and then another one over
Lake Huron on I believe February 4th I
think those were the dates and
you know they're they're just these
small objects and uh we don't there has
been no definitive I mean not enough of
a definitive statement let's put it that
way about what they actually were or are
and they're having trouble collecting
the debris but um so there's there's a
kind of chaos around all of this and and
it's become this sort of
you know it's been kind of it heightened
and there's escalation that's been going
on after every day around this topic and
I just think I mean it's clear to me
that these are not alien objects and
that's been stated
um even though that some people say the
door is still open but clearly they're
not they're most likely Chinese
uh and
you know it's it's a little confusing as
to why that has not been stated more
clearly I don't know if people if
there's just um people aren't talking to
each other there's not an organized
messaging that's going on around it they
haven't found the debris from the
objects so they don't maybe don't feel
it'll be what they are although I
suspect they do know what they are